jake is in san diego hi jake welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave uh very excited to speak with
you
i am currently 24 years old and i just
graduated from law school
i have 130 000 in debt
all of its student loans i am starting a
job taking the bar in july and starting
a job
the first week of october that job is
going to allow me to refinance
through a bank at about two percent and
then
uh fixed and then on top of that i'm
gonna be making
a hundred and ninety thousand plus bonus
my question for you today is
does it make sense while i'm in baby
step two and aggressively paying down
the 130 000
to max my 401k no in a health savings
account
no that's that's that's uh baby step
four
yeah what what did you make this year
this year i didn't technically work but
the firm i'm going to be working for
sent me about 40
40 000 and i had another job so it's 46
000.
so did you pay any of that on to the
student loans
i paid tuition for my final year and
before i started listening to you i
actually
funded a wrap okay okay all right so
what my challenge would be would be to
live like a college student
you know what if i woke up in your shoes
i think you have
landed an unbelievably awesome job
absolutely and you have an unbelievably
awesome future ahead of you
would you agree with that uh yes
did i understand you correctly to say at
24 years old you're going to be making
190 000
next year uh yes okay
and you owe 130 000 in student loan debt
yes you know what i would do i would
live on nothing and i would be debt-free
in one year
absolutely okay
can you stay home jake um
i can't because of where my job is but
so i'm going to have to pay rent and
stuff
um where's the truck i'm working it's
going to be in new york city
and the hours are going to be very long
but um
as in manhattan yeah okay
you are not going to be debt-free in one
year you're not yeah okay
but you're going to be debt-free in two
years yeah okay
yeah you're not gonna definitely you're
not gonna you're not gonna be able to
buy housing and
you're not gonna pay for housing of any
kind in new york city and do what i was
talking about so you cannot live on
absolutely nothing but just the same
you've you've still landed a wonderful
income
yes and congratulations you obviously
were quite a star pupil in your law
school
because you got recruited by a big time
firm that's paying you big time money
way to go i'm so proud of you yeah well
done but listen don't fall into the trap
of doing what a bunch of the goobs that
got recruited with you will do
don't do it these goobs will be in debt
for 10 years because it's 2
you don't want to pay out two percent
bull crap son pay it off now
fast okay fast attack it bro
as fast as you can and jake this means
you you need to look for roommates
in new york you you need to really i
mean bro you are living
as cheap and as low as possible they're
going to work you 80 hours a week anyway
you're not going to have time to do
anything but work
right yeah what i'm expecting
yeah your first year out they're going
to try to kill you that's their job
yeah so yeah just just work all the time
do nothing
and pay debt and do that for a year and
a half to two years
you'll be free and all of your compadres
all of your peers will still be
struggling
with a hundred to two hundred to three
hundred thousand dollars worth of
student loan debt
and they'll all be walking around the
halls with their lips stuck out
and making a ton of money and have no
money
yeah and you son will be on your way if
you'll do what i say to do
not many people will do this but let me
tell you wealth is weird
even in the hallways of big time law
firms in new york city
wealth is weird there's a lot of people
walking around with their chest stuck
out act like they've got something and
all they got is payments
don't be one of those i want you to look
and act like you are
poor because you are you are deeply in
debt
and clean this mess up as fast as you
can
i don't know if you'll do it or not but
man if you don't
this conversation's gonna haunt you
later sure will